let's talk a little bit about
reciprocals now when you first learn
reciprocals some folks will immediately
tell you hey just swap the numerator and
the denominator so for example if i have
the fraction two-thirds the reciprocal
of two-thirds if i swap the numerator
and the denominator is 3 halves if i had
the fraction
5 6 the reciprocal of that is going to
be 6 over 5.
and that's all well and good but what
does this actually mean
well one interpretation of a reciprocal
is it's the number that when you
multiply it by the original number you
get one so two-thirds times three halves
well c is equal to one or five-sixths
times six-fifths is equal to one another
way to think about reciprocals are
how many of that number or how many of
that fraction fit into one so if i were
to take one and i divide it by two
thirds
one interpretation of this is saying how
many two thirds fit into one if i take
one divided by five six an
interpretation of this is how many five
sixths fit into one and we'll see that
three halves of a two-thirds fit into
one and we'll see that in a second or
that six-fifths of a five-sixths fit
into one
so let's start with a very
straightforward example
let's say that i have the fraction one
half
so if i have one half
if that whole rectangle is a whole this
is one half here so if i were to ask how
many one halves fit into one so one
divided by one half
how many one-halfs fit into one
well i have one one-half right over here
and then i would have another one-half
right over there
so we have two one-halves so this is
equal to two now you might be saying
wait two doesn't look like i just
swapped the numerator and the
denominator but you have to realize that
two is the same thing as two wholes so
the reciprocal of one-half is indeed two
over one or if you take two over one and
if you have two one halves that is
indeed going to be equal to one
but now let's work on two thirds things
that are a little bit more nuanced
so two-thirds here
i can shade that in that's one-third and
then
two-thirds so this right over here is
two-thirds
now how many of these fit into one if we
were to say what's one divided by
two-thirds well we can clearly get a
whole two-thirds into one and then we
can get another third which is half of a
two-thirds so we can have a whole
two-thirds and then half of a two-thirds
or one-and-a-half two-thirds so we could
say one divided by
two-thirds is equal to one and a half
well one and a half is the exact same
thing as three-halves so once again you
can see that three-halves times
two-thirds is equal to one or that
three-halves of a two-thirds fit in to
one
let's do another example
if we were to think about three-halves
so three halves would be let's see
that's a half
that's two halves
and then this is three halves right over
here so let me mark all of that so this
whole thing right over here
is
three halves
now how many three halves fit into a
hole
well you can see that you can't even fit
a whole three halves into a hole you can
only fit two of the three halves so one
one-half two-halves of the three-halves
so what you can see here is that this is
two-thirds of the three-halves so if you
say
one divided by
three-halves how many three-halves can
fit into one well you can always fit
two-thirds of a three-halves into one
and this is interesting because the
reciprocal of two-thirds is three-halves
and the reciprocal of three-halves is
two-thirds